welcome ladies and gentlemen so nice to
see so many of you here today
for this first and highly crucial
historical debate the first in our
historical debate series on this
important subject and with our four very
distinguished speakers here it's not
just it occurs to me a historical debate
it could equally well be starting off a
philosophy debate which is why we have
both philosophers and historians on our
panel here tonight and I think tonight
is all going to be about the
intersection of moral principle and
historical fact and the extent to which
historical fact may or may not incline
you to change your mind from the great
historical principle that antony
grayling cites in the title of his own
book on this subject whether it is ever
justifiable to bomb civilians and some
of the questions that you will probably
be asking yourself tonight
as we get more and more into the history
of this is for example if it were the
case that the bombing of civilians was
crucial in stopping Hitler becoming
victorious would that change your mind
would it change your mind if even that
if that were not the case you were
persuaded that the decision-makers of
the time were convinced it was the case
these are some of the things that I hope
you will be thinking about and our
speakers will be persuading you about as
as we as we go on to this evening now
let me just tell you briefly what the
structure of the evening is going to be
like we're going to have our four
speakers each deliver in a speech of 10
minutes and I'm going to be ruthless in
cutting them off at their ten minutes
because I know they will all want to go
on for longer you I when they finished
I'm then going
renounce the vote that you all made as
you came into this room some of you may
have said don't know some of you may
have been in favor of the motion and
some against and we will then open the
debate up to you the audience and we'll
take questions which you can direct at
the panel any one specifically or or
just a general question and then we will
have summing up speeches and discover
how if at all you have changed your mind
during the course of this evening all
right without more ado let us begin this
evening with our first speaker
Anthony grayling author of more than 20
books on philosophy and the founder and
head of a new private university the new
College of Humanities he's been quoted
as saying that 1/3 of your life is spent
asleep a third in Tesco's and the other
third is left to you to live as well as
you can which makes me think he's spent
too much of his life food shopping and
actually not enough doing philosophy
anyway over to you Anthony
thank you very much indeed I'm sure I
said Redford's I must begin with true
preliminary remarks the first is that in
my view but I'm sure we all share this
view the Allied powers principally by
certain Isis America and Britain in
their war against the Axis powers were
fully justified in conducting that war
and indeed is arguably the case that
they had a moral duty to win that war
because the Axis powers and in
particular Nazi Germany were criminal
regimes and speak up
they were criminal regimes and they they
had to be defeated have they not been
defeated the history of the world would
have been a very much more terrible one
the same thing to say is that the airmen
of the Royal Air Force Bomber Command
and the United States Army Air Force
bomb groups were extraordinarily brave
individuals we just seen the opening of
a monument to the men and women of
Bomber Command in James Park and Green
Park and I applaud that because I think
it is long overdue that they should have
a memorial for this the great courage
that they displayed 55,000 members serve
RAF Bomber Command died in the skies
over Germany that was a tremendous
sacrifice and nothing that I'm about to
say should detract from the fact that
they made that sacrifice it raises a
very difficult problem for those of us
who think that the bombing of civilian
populations is not a morally acceptable
way of going on or conducting a war
because it raises the great question
about people who were doing their duty
and who saw what they were doing as
being part of a great cause as indeed it
was the cause of fighting Nazi Germany
but I think that's a separate debate and
I do think there is something to be said
about it but there are months I had to
make havethey aim of persuading you that
bombing civilian populations the
indiscriminate attacks by night on
cities was not a good thing to have done
that we in looking back on the war
and thinking about how we conducted the
war should ask ourselves this question
given that it was a justified war a
right war and given that it was
something that we had to win does that
justify everything we did in the course
of it it's the old and difficult problem
does the end justify the means and I
want to argue that our view of the
choices made by RAF Bomber Command and
by the high command of our military
endeavour was in that one respect wrong
I don't say that all the activities of
Bomber Command were wrong of course the
great role that they played in the
summer of 1944 was crucial in other
respects their attacks on military and
economic and transport targets in Europe
were a very important contribution to
the winning of the war so it's one
particular thing that I concentrate on
and that is what was known as area boy
the bombing of cities now most of the
people who were engaged in planning and
carrying out that strategy most of them
not perhaps all of them a personal
bomber Harris himself as he's known and
would at some point or other in the
course of their education like
yourselves have spent a good deal of
time lying in the bath reading
Thucydides and so they would have
noticed the reason that the acidities
gave for writing his account at the
Peloponnesian War namely that war
Corson's moral fiber and blunts judgment
about the white wager act even in times
of dangerous conflict and Thucydides
pointed out that when metal Eenie the
city on the island of Lesbos broke its
treaty obligations to Athens and the
Athenians discussed what they were going
to do to punish this erstwhile Ally they
first decided that they regard a
massacre the citizens of mytilini but
the next day they changed their minds
they came to the view that to do that
would be so a bad example to other
allies than would certainly not be
working in itself travia's later the
island state of minnows broke its treaty
obligations to Athens and the Athenians
didn't even discuss it they just went
and massacred them and threw sympathy
said this is proof positive of the way
that thinking changes in times of
conflict now in the First World War
Germany bombed these islands sending
over Zeppelin's and gothis they were not
that many casualties in comparison to
bombing casualties in the Second World
War but they were just enough to
terrorize everybody who thought that if
bigger and better airplanes and bigger
bombers more bomb loads more bomb
tonnage were to fall on a country that
that would be the end of civilization in
that country this was a new and a
terrible weapon and people were very
frightened knowledge in fact the
argument was put by the high command of
the world Air Force after the first
world war that it was a necessity to
retain the Air Force as an independent
arm and to make sure that it would be
capable of delivering bombing attacks on
enemies of course it was thought that a
new Wars would be very very short they
would last only a few days because each
of their competent nations would bomb
the other and it would be a matter of
who could endure the longest and the
leaders of the RAF at that time thought
that since the next war would certainly
be against France and since the French
could never last as long as the English
in a bombing war it was very important
that we should have bombers and be able
to bomb them I'm more or less quoting
from the remarks of marshal trencher and
so planning for bombing was instituted
early and in the middle 1930s very very
large bombers were designed and brought
into production and in the first years
of the 1940s there came into service in
the area beautiful aircraft like that
mr. bomber and the Halifax and others
but in 1939 when hostilities looked
inevitably President Roosevelt of the
United States wrote to Neville
Chamberlain and to Hitler and he said to
them given the experience of Guernica of
what happened in the first world war and
given the very great danger to
civilization of the bombing weapon
would you please both give an
undertaking that you won't use the
bombing weapon against civilians and
they both undertook to do this but it
didn't take very long for Nazi Germany
to be in breach of that undertaking but
it took some time for Britain to be in
breach of that undertaking for quite a
while in the first year of the war at
the RAF bombers were not allowed to
carried live weapons across the
coastline of the continent in case the
bomb fell out and hurt somebody they
carried lively munitions in their raids
against the German fleet but they didn't
carry live weapons until the attack in
the West until Germany invaded Belgium
and France and 10th of May and after
that of course the Dove started to come
off but it wasn't until 1941 that the
order to RAF Bomber Command was changed
as to what their target would be the
great inaccuracy of bombing the the
danger of trying to bomb by day meant
that the RAF had to change its tactics
the night bombing
night bombing proved almost futile it
was so inaccurate and so the the order
went out that the main target was going
to be the morale of the enemy population
and this meant that there was going to
be a bombing by night indiscriminate
bombing of civilian populations and
that's what happened and he went on
right the way through the war everybody
thinks of Dresden at the end of March of
1945 Churchill himself sent a message to
Sir Charles Porco who was the commander
Dornan Air Force etc the terror bombing
of Germany he used this phrase must stop
because we are coming into possession of
a ruined land and portal sent a message
back and said you can't send the message
like this to me or accusing me of a war
crime and Churchill had to rephrase the
message but the original was kept on
file was published in 1960 this was the
result of Churchill's horror
happened to dress no anxiety then read
about what post-war sentiment would be
but right back in 1943 the terrible
attacks on Hamburg the operation of
Gemara attacks in Hamburg showed
something of what was involved in the
nature of bombing and just to tell you
very briefly because you've no doubt
knows something about it the bottom of
the second night of the raids I had that
of course a tremendous fast thought in
which more people died than in Dresden
about 45,000 people most of whom died of
suffocation in their cellars because all
the oxygen was taken out of the air in
the city by the raging fire storm that
was started using mainly incentive bombs
after high explosives had blown off
walls and blown out windows and doors so
that the fires could spread and people
who were caught in the fires were shrunk
to the size of dollars by the tremendous
heat and a very early form of napalm was
used a kind of petroleum gel which when
it splashed onto people and had started
burning and made them jump into the
canals and Hamburg and into the docks
but when they were out of the water
these people reignited there was a very
very terrible weapon it was designed to
be so in 1949 the Fourth Geneva
Convention was adopted and in the
drafting of it an effort was made to
include a clause that would outdoor the
indiscriminate attacks on civilians and
the United States government and the
British government refused to accept
attacks clause because it would look
like a retrospective criticism of what
they had done in the cities of Germany
but also of course in Japan and in some
ways more terribly even in Japan and in
1977 a protocol two protocols were added
that the first column was the perfect of
the did the pound floor attacks
indiscriminate attacks on civilian
populations the government of the United
Kingdom signed that protocol the United
States of America to this day is not a
signatory to that protocol but by
accepting the first the attempt to
outlaw attacks on civilians and then
finally by adding their protocol to the
four
Geneva Convention the international
community has resolved on the basis of
the experience of the two world wars
that allowing artillery or bombing
attacks to be directed without any
precise desire to destroy a transport
thing or an aircraft Factory or
ball-bearing Factory or military
installations but just indiscriminately
to attack and terrorize the civilian
population would not be acceptable and I
think that what is true now of
international sentiment on that applies
throughout history it applied certainly
2,500 years ago and Thucydides thought
about something rather Caramel that kind
of message so my argument is that when
we look back on our experience of
conducting the Second World War we
should ask ourselves the question did
everything we do passed muster when we
look in hindsight with all the benefit
of course and safety of hindsight we
look back on it are there any lessons we
can learn and surely the lesson is that
that was not the right way to go I'm
sure my colleague would explain that
there were alternatives other things
that we could have done that might very
well it'd be more effective in the wall
but the crucial point for us is the
moral point thank you very much
thank you very much Anthony now our next
speaker started his career and became a
very distinguished foreign and war
correspondent and over the past decade
has emerged as one of Britain's most
exciting military historians I'm sure
many of you read bomber boys fighter
boys he seems to crank out a book every
other year and when he's not doing that
he's writing a novel and Afghanistan and
the hell of it is he's only a couple of
months older than I am there is and
gentleman patrick bishop
good evening I'm going to start with a
couple of quotations the first was
delivered in a BBC radio commentary
broadcast a few days after the RAF had
just launched its first thousand bomber
raid on Cologne on the night of 30 30th
to the 31st of May 1942 I quote in 1914
when the Germans were bombing Britain
they did not expect retaliation on a
very heavy scale the speaker said they
were not afraid to boast in their
propaganda about the slaughter of
civilians which they were bringing about
and the terror which their raids aroused
now when the tables have turned they're
beginning to cry out against the whole
business of aerial bombing which they
declared to be both cruel and useless
the people of this country are not
revengeful but they remember what
happened to themselves two years ago and
they remember how the Germans talked
when they thought themselves safe from
retaliation now the speaker was George
Orwell a very English man and a man you
might think with a very highly developed
conscious conscience when he said this
in the very early days of the mass
bombing of German cities 469 people were
killed in the Cologne raid most of them
civilians which was nothing compared to
what was to come but as as the attacks
grew heavier and civilian deaths
multiplied all wells line did not waver
my second quotation comes from a German
it too was made in a radio talk
broadcast from America just after the
town of Lubeck had been attacked and
large parts of it destroyed by the RAF
in the first fire bombing of a German
town
I think of Coventry said the speaker in
reference to the Luftwaffe bombing of
Coventry in November 1940 and I have no
objection to the lesson that everything
must be paid for did Germany believe
that she would never have to pay for the
atrocities that leap into barbarism
seems to allow the words are those of
Thomas Mann the great German novelist a
son of Lubeck and himself the voice and
conscious conscience
of the German civilization that Hitler
and Nazism had overwhelmed and perverted
like all well man stuck to this view
even when the war was over and German
cities had been reduced to bones and
ashes so here we have two men of
unassailable moral rectitude who lived
through these terrible events who would
challenge the proposition that we are
debating here tonight now there are some
crucial words in that sentence lived
through these events what we mustn't do
what we have no right to do is to look
back at terrible episodes of history
such as the bombing of Germany
undoubtedly wars and apply the values
and the knowledge that we have today to
decisions that were taken in desperate
times and those were desperate times for
Britain in the spring of 1942 when
Arthur Harris had just taken over at
Bomber Command and the process of area
bombing as the bombing of cities was
known began the war was very much going
Germany's way Britain had suffered
defeat after defeat in North Africa our
forces were on the defensive German
armies but deep inside Russia and it
seemed likely that before the summer was
out Hitler would be master of the whole
of Europe by now we knew what that meant
in January 1942 German bureaucrats had
spent the weekend in a pleasant villa at
van Z in the suburbs of Berlin planning
the murder of every Jew they could get
their hands on it wasn't just the Jews
it was homosexuals roms the mentally
feeble indeed anyone who was deemed to
present any threat by thoughtful by deed
to Germany's plans or who was merely
associated with someone who might was
liable to be killed there was no
negotiation with Nazi Germany no
compromise was possible the choice was
enslavement or death of course by now
Britain was no longer alone America was
a belligerent
but her forces were not yet in Europe if
we were to carry on the fight we had to
do it with our own
and in 1942 the only weapon we had in
our hands the only way we could reach
out and take the water Germany was the
air crews and machines of Bomber Command
now until now as Professor grayling has
said Bomber Command had had a disastrous
war a few of the extravagant claims made
for it before the conflict started had
turned out to be true the proponents of
strategic bombing as it was called had
held out the prospect of bombers ranging
deep into Germany striking with great
accuracy at the vital organs of its war
industry oil refineries factories and so
on and paralyzing its ability to fight
but Bomber Command was nowhere near
capable of delivering pinpoint strikes
on strategically important targets
indeed their efforts were almost
ludicrously inaccurate things they were
changing the arrival of Arthur Harris at
the head of Bomber Command coincided
with the arrival of the big four-engine
bombers the Sterling then the Halifax
then the Lancaster on the squadrons and
they carried big payloads of bombers
nonetheless Bomber Command was still a
very blunt instrument new more accurate
navigational aids were coming in OBO
then G and later improved bomb sights
and marking techniques but the RAF was
still a long way from being able to
deliver the surgical strikes beloved of
the airpower theorists now to be sure
the air crews would far rather have been
bombing oil refineries and steel works
and barracks than cities all that the
same cannot be said for Arthur Harris of
course but this was not possible on any
meaningful scale at this stage of the
war and would not be so for another two
years and this went for the Americans of
the US Army Air Force when they began
they began arriving in Britain as well
as the RAF no in 1942 the smallest
target the RAF could hit was a town or a
city so that with the approval of
virtually everyone in the political and
military establishment is what they did
this was a momentous decision to take
and it was known to be so
Britain had started the war as Professor
grayling said determined to avoid
civilian casualties and crews have been
under the strictest instructions not to
Menace population centers no one neither
the planners nor the crews nor the
public at large was under any illusion
about what the decision would mate would
mean for the people living in those
German cities yet it went ahead why the
answer is simply because the only
alternative to bombing cities was a
policy of passivity passivity in the
face of great evil and that for most was
not an option everyone in Britain was
united in their determination to resist
and defeat Germany and most believed
that it should be done by whatever means
possible that included the air crews
about a hundred and twenty thousand men
passed through Bomber Command of those
very few doubted the Justice of what
they were doing during or after the war
if they survived and of course fifty
five thousand of them didn't there were
some brave voices in both houses houses
of parliament as well as the church in
the press who spoke out against the
perceived barbarity of bombing but most
Britons approved the attitude can be
summed up in the words of one man
interviewed by Mass Observation on the
streets of Coventry just after the 1940
raid
we're fighting gangsters he said so
we've got to be gangsters ourselves
we've been gentlemen too long in other
words the Germans have started the war
they had conducted it with unparalleled
brutal brutality therefore the normal
rules did not apply by abandoning
restraint by ignoring all the laws of
war such as they were the enemy had
forfeited any right to restraint being
shown towards them such are the moral
compromises that war inevitably brings
about but this wasn't a simple matter of
pointless revenge
those engaged in bombing Germany
believed that they were hastening its
military and industrial collapse that
they were helping to bring the end of
the war closer a war that every day
you'd meant the deaths of tens of
thousands of innocents at German hands
now some of the assumptions behind the
campaign would turn out to be profoundly
wrong notably the idea that German
morale would crack and force the
collapse of the regime
I would also disagree with a decision to
carry on bombing cities into 1945 when
it served little or no useful military
purpose but in many respects the
planners and directors were right the
campaign did hasten the end it's easy to
lose sight in the controversy over area
bombing of the fact that Allied bombing
did vast damage to German war industry
and the German war effort
Antony Bevo will explain just how much
the damage may not have been as
extensive as hoped for or claimed but
how much stronger would Germany have
been if the Allied airforces had not
made those great efforts in closing I'd
like to say two things when considering
how justified the bombing campaign it
was I'd ask you to view the question not
through 21st century eyes but from the
perspective of those living in the worst
years of the war when Britain was
fighting a monstrous enemy with
extremely limited means then I think
you'd share the judgment of noble
Frankland Lancaster navigator who
survived numerous missions and went on
to write the official history of the
strategic air campaign he wrote that in
the early years of the bomber war when
it seemed that the campaign might
actually be abandoned that the great
immorality opened to us was to lose the
war against Hitler's Germany to have
abandoned the only means of direct
attack which we had at our disposal
would have been a long step in that
direction and finally I'd ask you to
think about the words of Thomas Mann the
good German who I quoted at the
beginning which appears in his post-war
novel dr. Faustus then the rater looks
around at the pulverized cities with
anguish but I cannot allow myself to
forget he says that terrible though
German defeat is it is nothing compared
to the thought of the horror of German
victory thank you very much
thank you very much Patrick
now our next speaker is not only one of
the foremost historians of the Second
World War he has also been and I know
may still be times editor of V and I
want you to take this word very
seriously complete history of the world
this guy knows a thing or two he's also
a man of whom the late Eric Hobsbawm
called erudite which coming from Hobbes
born is a compliment indeed ladies and
gentlemen Richard over it well thank you
very much for those kind words of
introduction I'm going to approach this
debate from the entirely different angle
and indeed I think between us we've
divided up a debate I think two very
different ways what I'm going to talk
about today are about strategic options
and about the options have opened to the
RAF or indeed to the British war effort
during the course of the Second World
War and I want to start off by reminding
us of the two strategic aims that
bombing the space to have when it was
undertaken in 1940 the first is that it
would unhinge the enemy's war effort the
second thing is that it might produce a
political dividend by profoundly
demoralizing the enemy population
compelling them to put pressure on the
Hitler government and possibly producing
surrender now there are three things I
think to observe first about these
ambitions the first is that in 1940 or
39 when the area thought about doing
this there was no evidence for the
sustained bombing campaign
would do either of those things indeed
the only evidence had been was a rather
half-hearted and small bombing offensive
at the end of the First World War whose
results were completely inconclusive
the only experience that the RAF had had
Pamyu course was so-called colonial
policing in which a handful of aircraft
would fly over some kind of tribal n
played cops and bombs drive the tribe to
surrender and as a result allowing the
RAF to claim that bombing had immediate
and clear results the serious bombing in
the nineteen thirties was in the Spanish
Civil War
now what striking I think is that the
RAF was among the major air forces the
only one looked at the Spanish Civil War
did not draw the obvious conclusion the
bombing didn't achieve a great deal but
the aircraft in support of ground forces
where the naval forces or the army did
achieve a great deal and it explains why
the soviet air force the german air
force from the french air force by 1940
41 were more or less air forces
committed to combined arms operations in
support of surface the surface forces
the third thing is preparation
now I many I'm sure know the story that
in 1940 Bomber Command despite all the
commitments of the 1920s and 1930s was
fundamentally unprepared to launch an
invasion of any magnitude against the
German homeland indeed was unable to do
so until well into 1943 what's even more
striking I think is the paradox but it
precisely matter in the calm of command
was thinking about what he was going to
be doing in the late 1930s a great deal
of Britain's
as being devoted to building up radar
chain and fighting command an extensive
civil defense is precisely to
demonstrate that it was possible to
combat bombing the bombing bomber would
not always get through and the RAF
operated in 1940 was extraordinary
schizophrenia one half of it saying we
could defend well against bombing or
effectively enough the other saying that
we could bomb and achieved something
decisive my Aikman dissident by 1940
there really was no strategic
justification for what it was the Bomber
Command was claiming in that sense the
campaign once he got going was not very
strategically justifiable now what made
this point even more obvious of course
was the Blitz the Blitz demonstrated if
you needed demonstration first of all
the long term and intensive bombing did
not break morale indeed this was the
biggest offensive had ever been and
never had been an offensive in which
40,000 civilians were killed away from
the fighting front here it was different
scares of course people worried about it
but in fact this war no British morale
did not break nor was the British
economy affected much by the Blitz
calculations made in the summer of 1941
by the ministry of home security
showed that Britain's economic potential
would be reduced by about five percent
and was quickly made up again after May
1941 not all of this was known to the
RAF and discussed the need in the air
ministry so there had to be some
additional justification for why you
wanted to persist with the bombing
campaign one of them was the argument
that the Germans were nowhere near as
tough as the British upon the Germans
they're bullies by Nature said they will
fold up when the British didn't fold up
the other was to look at some of the
evidence
distorted or misinterpreted the most
obvious example I've come across was the
evidence of absenteeism a great deal of
anxiety about whether bombing would stop
workers going to work whether they'd
stay away for months when the production
collapse as a result so the Ministry of
Home Security undertook a number of
detailed studies of places that had been
heavily bombed and they found that
workers in fact returned in most cases
within two or three days in Liverpool
even in Clydebank
which was heavily hit by bombers in the
end three quarters or more of workers
were back at work after two or three
days they needed to of course they need
to be paid they needed to look after
their families now this evidence was in
fact used by mojoville and others to
argue for the D housing and bombing of
German cities by looking those figures
simply disregarding what they showed
Churchill was told that the evidence
from harm and then important songs on
made it clear if you bombed heavily
enough workers would stay away from work
it wasn't true and it wasn't true in
Germany in 1944 absenteeism rates as a
result of bombing around about four
percent of all absenteeism there was
greatly or more absenteeism as a result
of regular leave holidays or illness
nonetheless Bomber Command persisted
have to say that they persisted in the
teeth of greatly the criticism from the
Army and the Navy that bit of light as
aircraft to be used for something else
and those resources to be diverted to
something else and at the end of what
was the outcome well we've heard already
this evening that bombing achieved a
great deal that it did if that meant
water citizen killed 350,000 people but
in terms of economic effects those were
muted even by 1944 when Germany has been
subjected to the heaviest air assault
has ever been it was possible to expand
output considerably up in September of
that year in Germany morale of course
never cracked in the sense that people
hoped it would
it was never a political overthrow or a
political crisis I want to end by saying
that interesting enough this is not just
my view it was also the few thing rref
in 1947 more tedder who had been Iceland
house deputy was not chief of staff
conducting what was called exercise
thunderbolt it was a high-level exercise
the fearful day's report of airmen and
experts came together and they look back
and they thought about what bombing had
done and was it worthwhile I'm very
shocked by two speeches which were made
by Norman Bottomly who was the deputy
chief of the air staff the man
responsible for sending the orders to
Harris all the time during the last
possible war and what Bottomly said was
we have to be honest about Bomber
Command
it was completely unprepared and didn't
know what he was doing the first few
years of the campaign but the critical
question what did it do forced him to
conclude in this audience first of all
that morale in Germany was never
critically affected by bombing and
secondly that the industrial system of
Germany located in its major cities was
also never critically undermined by
forming I think that's quite a stunning
indictment of a campaign which Bottomly
was of course partly responsible for
conducting now the implication of what
I've said in concluding that the
implication of what I've said of course
is resources might well have been used
for something else
what else could they've been used for
well this is a counterfactual and I'm
not going to spend time now exploring
all that counterfactual all this
contractual possibilities but if it's
something anybody wants to raise in the
discussion afterwards
I certainly have
thank you very much Richard now our next
speaker the author of such major
bestsellers Stalingrad Berlin the
downfall 1945 and the second world world
war really needs no introduction because
if you haven't heard of him
you have probably mistaken Reba for
Tesco's where you might we might not
find Antony great he says this I expect
the worst both from reviewers and sales
and then with any luck I may be proved
wrong well he certainly has been proved
wrong in that regard let's hope that
they has saved that he's not from wrong
tonight
Antony beaver
thank you very much Oh Nietzsche was
right when he wrote he who fights with
monsters should look to it that he
himself does not become a monster but in
warfare especially in total warfare
moral rectitude is hard to maintain in a
fight for national survival it's easy to
forget this when applying retrospective
judgment for a position of safety long
afterwards surely the point is to
understand first why things were done
and then decide whether the
circumstances of the time justified them
or not the Germans started the bombing
of cities Marin Madrid Durango Guernica
in the Spanish Civil War the destruction
of Warsaw followed in September 1939
Rotterdam in May 1940 then there was the
machine-gunning of refugee columns by
local fighters this was followed by the
Blitz on London by the bombing of
Coventry Belgrade Heraklion Minsk
Smolensk Leningrad Moscow Voronezh
Starling grad and countless other towns
and cities in the Soviet Union and I'm
not aware of many German civilians like
English British civilians objecting to
this at the time even in private the
Luftwaffe attacks may not provide a
perfect legal justification for bombing
German cities in return yet it certainly
constitutes a pretty natural reaction in
the circumstances especially when the
overwhelming majority of the British
public say nothing of the oppressed
populations in occupied Europe were
crying out for retaliation but revenge
was not the motive at least not the
primary motive bomber commands early
attempts to restrict its targeting to
military objectives in daylight were a
total failure in 1939 and 1940s you've
already heard and even throughout 1941
when area bombing began by night RAF
aircrew losses were often higher than
the German casualties they inflicted
bombing techniques especially during the
long periods of bad visibility over
northern Europe was simply not accurate
enough to focus on smaller targets
Churchill was horrified in late
September 1941 when you received the but
report
he's estimated from
reconnaissance that anyone aircraft in
five dropped their bombs within five
miles of the target this was a truly
desperate time the Vermont was advancing
on Moscow and almost everybody expected
that the Red Army would collapse the
implications for Britain facing Germany
alone were terrifying Churchill with his
eye on Moscow was acutely conscious of
Britain's blood guilt the knowledge that
the Red Army was taking almost all the
casualties while grinding down the verm
out the Soviets eventually lost nine
million servicemen and women killed and
15 million badly wounded this was more
than 23 times as many as the United
Kingdom in any case Churchill although
furious with the RAF over the inaccuracy
of the bombing revealed in the bat
report could not deny our chief marshal
portal's argument that the British Army
could do very little only the RAF could
intervene with the aerial bombardment of
targets in Germany portal recommended
the Bomber Command should be increased
to 4,000 heavy bombers the Soviet Union
sent time had no long-range bomber force
capable of hitting targets in Germany so
for Britain to do nothing all to try to
bomb isolated military installations at
a horrendous cost in RAF air crew was
unthinkable solid nevertheless refused
to acknowledge ChaCha's argument that
the strategic bombing campaign was a
surrogate for the second front which he
had been said vociferous ly demanding
yet he concurrently showed considerable
interest and there's no doubt that from
the autumn of 1942 the Allied bombing of
Germany began to hurt Vermont morale on
the Eastern Front even if it didn't
crack civilian morale at home but much
more to the point
Hitler's anger with Goering over the
Luftwaffe inability to stop the Bombers
getting through force Nazi Germany to
withdraw the bulk of its fighter
squadrons and its 88 millimeter
anti-aircraft guns from the Eastern
Front to defend the right by 1944 there
were just 1,200 heavy anti-aircraft guns
left for the whole of the Eastern Front
yet more than 7,000 back in Germany and
if
88-millimeter anti-terror aircraft guns
which were the most devastating
anti-tank weapons to the whole war had
not been withdrawn from the eastern
front one dreads to think how many more
say that soldiers would have died this
concentration of firepower in Germany
altogether 15,000 heavy and light
anti-aircraft guns also affected the
Western Front come d-day by June 1944
there any 132 of those 88 millimeter
guns in the whole of Normandy must not
forget that this gun used in an
anti-tank role destroyed many more
Allied tanks in the Second World War
than German Panzers managed to so the
already heavy losses of British and
American tank crews in Norman it could
have been a massacre even more decisive
to the outcome of the war was the
withdrawal of Luftwaffe fighter
squadrons and formations from the
Eastern Front to defend German cities
and this gradually tipped the balance of
air superiority away from the Luftwaffe
to such a degree that by 1944 he could
hardly send any reconnaissance flights
over the Soviet lines and this allowed
the Red Army to prepare the huge
deceptions which culminated in Operation
Bagration the destruction of Army Group
center in Bella Russia the most
devastating victory of the whole war the
strategic bombing offensive as a whole
greatly accelerated Soviet advances on
the Eastern Front as a result and almost
certainly shorten the war considerably
as a result in fact one of bomber
commands attacks on the roar here on the
12th of March 1943 destroyed the main
panzer construction center and thus
delayed the construction the production
of the new panther tank since Hitler was
relying on this new tank for the
upcoming Kursk offensive this greatly
contributed to its continual
postponement all the way from April
until July 1943 by that time when the
battle finally started the Red Army was
well dug Ian and waiting and the titanic
clash at Kursk smashed the fur marks
panzer arms such a degree that some
historians have cited Kursk was one of
the major turning points of the war Air
Chief Marshal Harris the head of Bomber
Command
did not give a jot about any
except his own self-defined mission of
breaking German resistance he became
even evermore obsessed with his belief
that the bombing of cities would shorten
the war and thus save hundreds of
thousands of lives
Harris was certainly proved to be wrong
and I would never attempt Leighton
Patrick to justify the continued bombing
of German cities into 1945 but as the
great writer WG saybolt pointed out in
his book on the natural history of
destruction
the British had invested so much in
materials of treasure and manpower say
nothing of lives lost to develop Bomber
Command that they could not bear to stop
using it while Nazi Germany fought on
and that was the great tragedy for the
German people they'd been taken hostage
by their own leader who was determined
that they should die with him we must
remember that well we know today that
the Second World War in Europe was going
to end in May 1945 that was far from
clear at the time the shock of the
Ardenne offensive and the appearance of
German jet fighters and the new you
birds in the winter of 1944 made many
Allied commanders wonder whether the war
would drag on into 1946 and we should
not overlook some of the
misunderstandings about the bombing in
the autumn and winter of 1944 American
air force propaganda pretended that they
were hitting precision targets what they
called pickle barrel bombing while the
RAF just went on carpet bombing cities
but Bomber Command was in fact also
hitting oil targets when the weather
permitted in fact during this premiere
and third period the Americans achieve
just four percent more strikes on our
targets than the RAF a minimal
difference the idea that precision
bombing was possible all the time during
one of the worst periods for visibility
for many years is ludicrous the US 8th
Air Force had to drop more bombs
nonvisually which in fact meant copied
bombing an area target than it could
visually the question that we must ask
ourselves is how would the war have
turned out if he had not used our heavy
bombers against Nazi Germany the ver
mark was defeated almost entirely on the
wet Eastern Front it sustained 90% of
its casualties
the strategic bombing campaign was our
any way of helping the Red Army until we
could land armies in northern Europe the
Nazis invented total warfare in their
brutal invasion of Poland in September
1939 they showed no distinction between
soldiers and civilians in their
subsequent invasion of the Soviet Union
14 million civilians were bombed shot
and starved to death in addition to the
nine million military dead a militarily
weaker Britain could hardly hope to
achieve anything against such atrocities
with conventional land and sea warfare
once again I would like to emphasize
that we must understand the situation as
it really was at the time we should be
careful when indulging in the luxury of
moral judgment with the hindsight of
seventy years thank you very much
thank you very much Anthony now we come
to the second part of this evening when
we throw the floor open to all of you
and I shall be taking questions please
try to make them short and to the point
and I will probably be taking them three
at a time do feel free to have put them
to any specific member of the panel or
make them general questions just before
we go ahead with that I should like to
enlighten you about what you all felt
before you had the opportunity of
hearing our distinguished panel no doubt
you already in the process of changing
your mind one way or the other but
here's what you felt when you came in to
this auditorium for the motion that the
Allied bombing of German cities in world
war ii was unjustifiable 83 of you
against the motion a hundred and thirty
six but and here is the interesting
point from the point of view of finding
out who wins this debate at the end of
the evening 96 96 of you when you came
through the door professed that you
didn't have an opinion or didn't know
which way to vote I hope you're
beginning to feel that now you do but
it'll be very interesting to see at the
end of the evening which way you do vote
now I'm going to ask questions the
roving mics will come to you you can see
them around and about please put up your
hand people who have questions to ask
okay we've got one here in the front
person in this room of a certain age who
lived through the war London in the
Brits
who doesn't really believe that had the
Germans been able to do any more than
they did but they wouldn't have done and
just to make a point if I may we can't
hear you without the microphone - you
would have had is why he maybe would
have stopped the area bombing much
sooner
although the accepted theory is that the
Germans weren't anywhere near and atom
bomb it was by no means sir the way they
covered up their offensive well that's
an interesting observation I didn't hear
a question in that but nevertheless I'm
sure we will take that on boards it
wasn't impossible for the journalist the
track of an atomic bomb and a lot of
people in authority have said that even
after the British crossed the Rhine had
the Germans got an atomic device alright
I get your question there and we'll come
we'll come to that to what extent were
High Command aware of all right rightly
or wrongly that the Germans might have
been developing a bomb next question
Thank You mr. chairman
it seems to me that we as often happens
in these debates dialogue at the death
very interesting dialogue was it is the
question I'd like to ask those opposing
the motion is not whether which they
seem to be asserting that strategic
bombing could be and was useful but
perhaps not useful as it could have been
but whether in fact we should have
continued to have aerial bombing of
large cities with as I understand it
limited morale and economic consequences
should we not have done something else
excellent and then that one last
question all right we'll take it from
over there
the crucial question seems to me to be
what what best could the British Armed
Forces do have done in the circumstances
so Anthony Besler has argued it seems to
me rather plausibly that probably the
most effective thing they did do was
what we have just been described the
bombing but Richard over he says there
are the were other better things more
effective well that's an interestingly
allied question to the one before was
there and watch it so we have two
questions a panel perhaps Patrick you
clean since points what do you talk
about the atomic first one but I think
most people would agree that after the
invasion of northwest Europe took hold
they were diminishing returns on bombing
German cities both morally and
practically the practical argument
against it being that they were actually
by that stage by the time you've got to
the to the frontiers of Germany laying
waste to towns that would then have to
be rebuilt the actual business of
demolishing a town made the defenders
job easier and the attackers job harder
and it became more and more difficult to
explain why large numbers of civilians
were being killed and even after Dresden
even out the outrage that Dresden caused
pretty much immediately the bombing went
on such was the power that Harris had
over his political masters he was able
to carry on said towns like Ford
full-time which had very little military
bearing whatsoever were demolished by
this stage they've got the system down
so well that it was it was kind of more
or less had raised in the space of half
an hour so I think there's not much
debate really about there are many
people who are going to say that it was
a good idea to carry on
pounding German cities to rubble was the
question raised about the fear of an
atomic bomb a realistic one I think of
that stage that well the main problem
had been the V weapons which an enormous
amounts of effort had gone into
destroying
after they came into use in the summer
of 1944 but I don't think there was a
feeling that the continued bombing of
cities was in any way linked to the
prevention of the development of an
atomic bomb no thank you can we just
turn to the second two questions there
Richard you make the point that a good
alternative would have been bombing and
to back up the Armed Forces and that
kind of strategy but what would that
have done to address Antony beavers
point about facilitating the Soviet
advance in what sense would one level no
point of rewriting history history
happened something I think is that in
the 1930s there are opportunities which
other Air Force's took to focus on a
different range of aircraft types to
focus on very high performance medium
bombers to focus on the sort aircraft
which would be capable of supporting the
Armed Forces or indeed of independent
operations against military targets or
indeed developing a fast and accurate
bomber like the mosquito which would be
capable of reaching targets in Germany
doing real damage to particular targets
rather than City bombing which is simply
a blunt instrument you know whatever
arguments one can see for it in terms of
military expediency at the time it is a
blunting symptom is known to be a blunt
instrument so focusing on if we think
for a moment but all those productive
resources all those scientific research
resources are now being devoted to
something else the naval war might well
have turned out very differently then
army support might have meant that the
British
he was a much more effective force
earlier in the war than it was it might
be possible to imagine Crete not being
captured for example it's possible to
imagine the North African campaign being
completed very rapidly in britain's
favor it's even possible to imagine
singapore being better supported than it
was so once you actually take a
commitment of strategic bombing out of
the picture it's a very large commitment
then you've got a range of options that
you might undertake which were the same
options that we use for the Germans or
the Soviets and so on
the dial might look very different if an
enemy that was a decent alternative why
didn't why wasn't it used what when one
looks at what Richard was suggesting the
way that for example missed imitating
the way that the Luftwaffe actually does
the sort of close support arm to the
German army that was Richard never much
on the table but that gets back even
further I guess back as I think he
mentioned to the 1918 and sort of the
RAF of desperation to be a sort of
separate strategic arm so one has to
accept that one as a given whether you
like it or not and if you're talking
about saving Singapore or any of that I
mean at that stage the resources hadn't
really gone in to the heavy bomber
investment how many was it was about to
start it was starting but it wasn't
really until sort of 4243 that one was
really seeing that major investment in
materials treasurer that they shouldn't
they should have been investing in
something else if they had had a
slightly more conscientious view about
what it was a play to have held the
British Army in in in France in 1940
because there they did have a lot of
light bombers unfortunately they were
totally obsolete and useless I mean
there's both pilots of the ferry battles
were just massacred and that was to a
certain degree the case Crete wouldn't I
didn't think of being saved in that
particular
she mentioned now I think that when one
looks at the whole question of the
Eastern Front and let us face it it was
the Eastern Front as I said which
actually destroyed the Burma which was
actually the decisive front of the whole
and theater of the whole war and that
was actually one area where we could
help when we did help at anything it was
necessarily planned in advance but
certainly Churchill recognized it the
moment of the crisis of 1941 developed
during that course of that summer there
was no other way of doing so as Annie
grayling hang on Richard Antony would
like a word about the alternative of
course the planning and design of heavy
bombers started in the middle of the 30s
not a 35 so that was already you know
they were already on course to do that
but it's been suggested that had the
development effort gone into providing
long-range anti-submarine patrols for
example in the North Atlantic been
powerfully argued that that would have
shortened the war considerably and that
was the one thing the Churchill said
kept him awake at night was the danger
to the convoys in the North Atlantic the
other thing that might have done what
might have been done is long-range
fighter cover for bomber forces so that
they could bomb by day and do it a bit
more precisely a second United States
Army Air Force they finally got
long-range fighter cover and as a result
became much more effective by day so
there are two very very practical things
that could have been done and just very
briefly if I may on Anthony Antony's
point about the Eastern Front and he's
absolutely right of course they've aged
88 millimeter guns were brought back
into Germany and fighter squadrons were
but that would have exactly the same
effect would have been achieved if the
bomber effort were directed at railway
lines and military installations and oil
refineries just as well as if they were
aimed at cities obviously going to come
back to it in one form or another I
imagine with your questions but I liked
to hear more from you and in particular
addressing how much of a shortened war
justifies the breaking of a moral
principle of how much
to shorten the war by for example and
did these strategies that both sides are
talking about facilitate that have we
got a question right at the back I would
like to question the advice look at
these issues in hindsight because I
think it's actually quite important to
apply our moral and ethical values of
today when we judge whether this was
justifiable or not because the UK is
involved in warfare today and there are
civilian victims today as well so what
we think today is very important and I
think when we both should we should
apply our world and ethical values that
we have today
is your question what's the nature of
your question I'm questioning how can
you support the advice to not use
hindsight when we decide whether it was
justifiable or not who do you feel is
not who do you feel is missing
making misusing hind some speakers
advised us not to use hindsight when we
judge so that's that's what I'm
questioning you think we should I think
we should okay in favor of hindsight
that's a new one that's a cook with very
interesting um our next question please
my name is Laura Nazi Germany for my
Oxford final so that's about as far as
my knowledge goes oh I have a question
for mr. Bishop which is that I at one
point you referred to Thomas Mann is a
good German and I think it's very
dangerous to make those there's sorts of
binary moral distinctions because with
an ideology like Nazism
there are obviously degrees of
permeation degrees of acquiescence in
the individuals among the population and
I think that to tar the entire
population with the same brush and then
to justify bombing as an attack on Nazis
Mahal when in fact we're targeting
individual Germans is very dangerous so
you can't use a single so-called good
german to justify an entire bombing
campaign no Germans might have been good
but they were affected by a wider
ideology so I don't know how you can
morally justify that even if you can
historically understand it thank you and
our third question
that's ready here I would just like to
ask the speakers in favor of the motion
they haven't they've mentioned quite a
bit about breaking morale in Germany but
they haven't mentioned the morale of
Britain and given that we were in a
somewhat David and Goliath situation and
we did we had you know far less
resources than those that we were
fighting we had there had to be a way to
have a will to carry on to have a will
to to carry on the fight and to believe
that we could win and none of the
speaker's really seem to have touched on
the morale of the British people at that
point in bridging your which you're
asking could only have been achieved by
aerial bombing of the sort day yes my
understanding of the morale of British
people at the time was that they had
suffered so much in terms of attack okay
let's begin with that question Antony
area bombing was very good for British
morale essentially so is that enough to
justify it you'll be very interested to
know that the mass observation unit
asked people during the war what they
thought about bombing Germany
and those who lived in cities that
hadn't been bombed we're all for it
and those who lived in cities that had
been bombed were very much against it on
the whole so that's a very interesting
finding I very much agree with the view
that that to make the entire German
population culpable for the actions of
the Nazis does raise a serious question
and then after all what turned the
Berlin population against the Allies
much more than they had been before
because they weren't very happy about
the Nazis was being bombed in the winter
of money 43 44 it happened that gurbles
was cheered in the streets having been
booed in the streets before then but the
point about hank's I think is is very
crucial of course we must use hindsight
of course it's comfortable and safe to
do it but if we don't learn anything
from history why aren't our study it
I get to take three more questions now
good evening my name is Mark from the
British kinematic graphics society and
my question is really about atomic
weapons and the very great possibility
that they would have been used had that
war as has already been said I had that
war dragged on in 246 b-29s were
stationed in East Anglia completely with
atomic weapons now the question is what
would have been the fallout had those
atomic weapons being used on their
primary targets which were in Germany as
opposed to the secondary targets which
turned out to be Hiroshima and Nagasaki
I think that's such an interesting
question we'll just take a quick panel
discussion on that Antony beaver correct
me on this but I mean I don't know of
any contingency planning for dropping
any atomic weapons on Germany so I'm
afraid that we're into counterfactual
areas here I mean apart from anything
else one has to remember that the
prevailing wind in Europe is westerly a
mist of radiation would have drifted
straight onto the Red Army and I didn't
think that Eisenhower or Roosevelt or
anybody would have been very keen on it
and a particular stage well it is the
case of course that the whole Manhattan
Project for atomic weapons was designed
originally for the Europe European war
and the European war gone on and if it
looked as if you know as a prospect
about I'd defeat sustaining that war on
in 1945 these are democratic countries
difficult to sustain it might have been
difficult to resist I think we can't put
our hands on our heart and say that it
wouldn't have happened the war ended of
course before it did but very quickly we
need to remember of course how often the
Americans and the British discussed the
use of chemical and biological weapons
the Germans very interesting now we had
two other questioners which I put off at
that time can we have those questions
please sorry yeah I've some limited
experience of working with the the MOA
and the military very limited but the
one thing I learnt from them is that
both sides love to play with the toys
and they they know the toys are going to
go out of date and therefore they want
to be used how much does the panel think
this this might have influenced the use
of heavy bombs and heavy bombers during
the Second World War they were there
therefore they had to be used in order
to demonstrate the might of the military
industrial complex
excellent and can we take one more
question from from from you sir over
there can we have the microphone over
here now I they had the judge with a
green tie I'm sorry my question is very
simple it seems to me that the
proponents of this motion I really rely
on the fact that it didn't work and look
basically if it had worked it would have
been an entirely different thing I'm not
sure that's a justifiable stance I also
think the point about the atomic bomb is
very interesting and I think I'd like to
ask a subsidiary question does the
permit educating well we all have your
first question was quite interesting
enough for us to do with two very
interesting was no no no sleeping or I'm
sneaking sorry I think they're very good
question that do we anywhere had to deal
with so so we've got those two questions
Anthony do you want to to start off
responding to the first of them I'm
sorry I've forgotten what the first of
the mises I was so distracted
right over and mark my own contribution
to this is specifically targeted at the
moral issue because it's naughty of
course independent of the question of
what else might have been done and could
have been done which would have been
equally or more effective but but I
think that the very fact that people
here felt that that the bombing of
civilian populations was barbaric should
have been something that set the alarm
bells off and we should really have
addressed the question that Bishop Bell
kept asking in the House of Lords about
it when he said we are fighting
barbarians why are we behaving like them
and I think that that was a serious
issue the committee against night
bombing which was a campaigning group
here during the war to try to persuade
the government and the royal air force
to use the weapons available in ways
that would have not involved mass mass
murder that mass attacks on civilian
populations women children the elderly
most of the military aged men were in
the services that this really was for
them as it is for us today a moral issue
with your own comms be put to rest were
you to be persuaded that those who made
the decision were convinced it would be
effective yes it would I think if you
look at Japan I think that does answer
the question because if you look at the
horrors of what the Japanese perpetrated
the battery on marches the the sea
voyages that they forced American
prisoners of war to go through that was
a justifiable bombing and if if you can
drop an atomic bomb and justified to end
a war well that's not moved into its
separate terrain and we don't want to go
that I want to pick up the second quench
well what was actually the question
before which was the boys toys question
and I suppose a spinoff from that the
fact that all this institutional and
capital energy had been put into
creating this strategy and these bombers
so we've got it let's use it was how
much was that rather than any finely
judged moral concerns the basis for
dumping all these bombs on civilians
Patrick
played a large part in in thinking and
planning when you look at the advent of
the arrival of Harris of Bomber Command
he's very keen to impress as soon as
possible and so he scraped together
every aircraft he could lay his hands on
for the first thousand bomber raid which
was as much a propaganda and publicity
stunt as it was an act of war he was
determined to show for his own vanity as
well as for genuine war winning reasons
that these big bombers if used
effectively could have a devastating
effect on on the progress of the war so
yeah that there was an element of that
and I wouldn't say it's the entire
reason there okay we've got time for two
more questions and two more questions
only the gentleman appeared there and
the gentleman would stand up there yes
my question is for Richard Overy does he
not think that the Royal Air Force was
justified in taking in learning
different lessons from both Spain and
Poland and may war France Germany and
Russia were huge continentally nations
with huge standing armies Britain was a
maritime nation with a miniscule
amateurish standing army and after May
he no army at all and two or three
hundred miles of water to cross before
they could take the war to the enemy so
your your question is that the acts of
the lesson from Spain was not as Richard
overi suggested it was is that right
when assigned to brace I believe that
the RAF was right to take different
lessons from what I could see that's
what will pick Richard I'll ask you to
answer that after we've had our last
question from the gentleman in the black
and white tie over there well spotted
tight well canals case he greatly what
his response to Otto Klemperer would
have been he was the german jewish
diarist who survived the holocaust as a
consequence of the bombing of dresden
and what would they see wailing have
said to him about in supported
outpatient okay two very different but
interesting questions and we better be
very quick now
if you want to get away on time first of
all Richard do you want to respond to
the charge that you have drawn the wrong
lessons there were plenty of lessons of
course to draw throughout the 1920s of
Surgeons you could have thought very
hard about air power as the other states
do and of course they got large
continental armies and they have long
frontiers but why did we then send an
expeditionary force to France expect him
in over three years we would build it up
and be able to contain and combat the
German armed forces without thinking at
all about the kind of aircraft you
needed to be able to support ground
forces effectively resources have been
put into that much earlier in 1930s and
the lessons of Spain have been learned
again the Battle of France
I know his speculation might well have
turned out differently
I finally Antony do you want to respond
if such terrible things were going on in
Europe why wouldn't one need to deal
with them in a comprehensive retaliation
well I'm major to the fact that great
discussions went on in especially in the
United States but also in the United
Kingdom about what to do with Germany
after the war this is a nation the
largest nation in Europe and in the
space of two generations after
unification had plunged the whole world
into into war and there were all sorts
of suggestions one was that Germans
should be sterilized then there wouldn't
be any more of them and they would have
caused any more Wars that was one sense
suggesting another to which Churchill
and Roosevelt actually signed up
temporarily was that Germany should be
split into two countries which did
indeed happen but they should be purely
agrarian countries and they shouldn't
have an industrial capacity so they
could make war the suggestion which I
thought was the best one was that the
use of Germany should be taken out to
various parts of the British Empire talk
cricket and then sent back to Germany
and then that would prevent
so I'm you know thinking during the war
about what the solution might be was was
very ingenious and very varied but when
one does look back on the war and thinks
about the experience of it and there are
very much larger lessons to be learned
there are lessons that invite us to go
back into the deeper history the the
deeper etiology of the Second World War
indeed back to the First World War
lessons we could learn but whether or
not it was reasonable to have thought
any other wise than those aware of what
was happening on Europe did think yes
because had they done that same kind of
thinking about earlier conflicts they
might have thought differently about how
to conduct that one
okay let's I'm afraid have to wrap up a
question time there though we'd love to
go on the final part of this evening is
going to be the summing up short summing
up speeches by each of our panelists
during which time ashes will be going
round with boxes into which you will be
casting your votes you all have a ticket
and entry slip which if you look at it
has yes and no on the back of it all you
have to do is rip it up and put either
yes or no for the motion that the Allied
bombing of German cities was
unjustifiable or no against the motion
if you feel it isn't and if you are
still undecided or are principled to
abstain err on this please put the
entire ticket into the box all right now
we're going to have summing up speeches
in reverse order which means if I'm not
mistaken but Antony
will you give us the benefit of your
conclusions I would just like to make a
couple of very quick points we've heard
certain arguments that the bombing
campaign was in many ways strategically
illogical in you could certainly say
that from certain points of view but it
also presupposes all of our military
doctrine should have been completely
different right from the start well I
think that's trying to create a sort of
an ideal world which simply didn't
didn't exist many of the reasons why it
had developed in the way that it was was
due to the formation of the Royal Air
Force in 1918 its desperation to be a
strategic arm and all the rest of it now
that is not necessarily a virtue at all
but at the same time it was a reality we
had to live with there were many reasons
why there was such an emphasis on our
power and on the reach of the heavy
bomber but when it actually came down to
it I will go back and I'm without
repeating myself too much emphasized
that particular point the war was won on
the Eastern Front and we did manage with
the Bombers rightly or wrongly we did
manage to make a real difference in that
particular way and very lastly I would
add that I totally disagree with the
argument that somehow hindsight should
be a major guide I mean as a historian
that actually is a complete historical
aberration I'm afraid you have to put
yourself into the shoes the boots or
whatever of the people at the time to
understand why they were thinking in the
way that they did and to understand from
that point of view before you start
making moral judgments I think it was
the historian it was Norman Davis who
described the way that we have a
tendency nowadays to try to impose the
values and I
years and morals infra like today on
previous eras which he described as a
psycho anachronism I think that that
actually is rather dangerous we've got
to understand what he was like at the
time from you at the time that the time
people might well have arrived to pay
differently to judgments about how
Britain used its resources
I'm not going to explore that again
because I think the counterfactual
arguments are slightly red herrings in
this case but two things I want to end
with the first is the fact that at the
time people realize what a blunt
instrument bombing was and it's one
statistic we haven't used tonight which
I think might surprise people is that
70,000 non-germans
died in France Norway Denmark the
Netherlands Belgium during the Second
World War as a result of Allied bombing
they were all people waiting to be
liberated and that's quite a sobering
thought when we tried to imagine what
bombing thought he was going to achieve
seventy thousand people who are not
those nasty Nazis that we were supposed
to be spending our time destroying the
second thing is I want to adjust the
question moral experience in hindsight
because it is all hindsight a lot of the
writing people get very excited about
judging the past with the present just
one small point is to recall that the
Chiefs of Staff sent out rules of
engagement to Britain's armed forces in
September 1939 they made it clear in
those rules of engagement the
bombardment by sea or from the air
against military targets which was
situated in areas where civilians lived
I cities was illegal somewhere between
that point and the decision that you
could begin bombing industry
later on bombing the central cities
deliberately there were acts of moral
expediency and I think we need to
acknowledge says Patrick your final
thoughts for some of the points that
Anthony's made have been really
fundamentally Britain and the RAF
started the second world war with a hand
that had been dealt in the interwar
years it's home aerial strategy was
based on on having a bomber fleet that
would reach her that either deter
Germany from attacking or if that didn't
work reach out and do fatal damage to
Germany's war industries and the German
war effort and so in 1942 when this
wasn't working and the but the big
bombers were coming along they were
where they were they only really had one
course of action and that was to go and
bomb Germany if we were to show defiance
if we were actually go to hurt the enemy
in any meaningful way that was really
the only choice we had blunt instrument
though it was just on the point that
Brit has just made about the 70,000
people who were killed in other
friendlies if you like who were killed
by bombing attacks that does make the
blunt instrument point but it also I
think would be regarded by the popular
the liberated populations as a price
that regrettably had to be paid and we
see that now in the in the honor and the
respect that's shown to to Bomber
Command in Holland and Scandinavia where
year after year they invite veterans
over and show their respect and and
their gratitude so to sum up because of
the realities of the situation and the
absence of hindsight bombing was both
inevitable and I think in the
circumstances justify
Thank You Patrick and finally Anthony um
well I wholeheartedly agree with other
Anthony that a good historian must think
himself or herself into the boots the
shoes the clothes of the people of the
time see things from their point of view
he's absolutely right about that I
wouldn't gainsay it for a moment and he
does it wonderfully well I love his
books but that is not inconsistent with
also trying to learn some lessons with
hindsight once the historians have told
us what was thought and down and said at
the time these are not inconsistent
things and there is a duty to do both
and the second duty has been done by the
international community the
international community in the UN and
the Geneva Conventions is now outlawed
the indiscriminate attacks on civilian
populations they still happen but it's a
good thing that that law now exists in
the international jurisdiction and if
it's wrong now and it was done because
of the experience of the Second World
War but we can't say that it became
wrong in 1949 or in 1977 when these
things were debated and enacted if they
are wrong now they were wrong then and I
think we we exemplify moral courage by
looking back at our actions even at a
time of great danger to us and of
tremendous urgency and importance that
we defeat this terrible enemy look back
on it and say nevertheless in the
process of doing it if only we've been
able to do something different because
we wouldn't like to do that again
well a gentleman thank you very much for
for being here and thank you the panel
for giving us such an excellent debate
before I announce the result
which i think is coming down the
right-hand channel as we speak or the
left-hand channel we're concerned I
should like to give you a foretaste of
but some of the history debates that
we're going to be staging next season
after Christmas we have to in mind
already and would love further
suggestions from any of you here but the
two we have in mind for your interest in
entertainment one involves Karl Marx and
the other involves Neville Chamberlain
and in both cases we're going to say
that both of these guys were right
and please do turn up and see whether
you agree or firmly disagree with that
the last point I'd like to make is that
we still haven't quite come to the nub
of at what point an absolute moral
principle should be altered by the facts
is shortening the war good enough or do
you have to be convinced that you may be
shortening the war by a few days is that
enough to overturn the principle that
you can bomb civilians or must have be
stronger than that and you must be
convinced that this is the actually the
only way of winning the war I don't know
don't know which of us does but anyway
it was an excellent debate and we're now
going to find what you thought right let
me remind you of what you did think when
you first came into this room 83 of you
were in favor of the motion that the
Allied bombing of civilian cities was
unjustifiable 136 of you were against
the motion and 96 of you didn't know
here are the new figures 10 of you still
don't know
a hundred and fifteen of you now support
the motion and a hundred and ninety one
are against it so I declare the motion
defeated thank you very much